-These are our favorite
jokes of the week.
[ Cheers and applause ]
President Trump said yesterday
that he plans to deliver
his speech
accepting the Republican
nomination from either
The White House
or the battlefield
at Gettysburg, Pennsylvania.
Okay, do you really want
your speech
getting compared to
the Gettysburg Address?
It's like announcing
you're going to film
the next "American Pie" movie
on the same set as
"Citizen Kane."
A 103-year-old woman in Michigan
got a tattoo last week
to check it off her bucket list.
Well, I just hope she doesn't
regret it when she gets older.
Russian President Vladimir Putin
announced today
that his country's healthcare
regulators have approved
the world's first
coronavirus vaccine,
despite the drug not
undergoing clinical trials.
Though it's definitely
not the first time
Putin has skipped the trial.
[ Russian accent ] Guilty.
Take him to roof.
A stunt double in England
recently set himself on fire
to propose to his girlfriend,
so he's extremely romantic
and, bonus,
he already knows
how it feels to be married.
♪♪